un equipo de 14 personas del oiea se
dirige a la central nuclear de sabor y
allá el jefe del organismo internacional
de energía atómica rafael grossi tuiteó
que deben proteger la seguridad de la
mayor instalación nuclear de ucrania y
de europa añadiendo que estaba orgulloso
de dirigir la misión a la planta esta
semana en declaraciones a france 24 la
semana pasada dijo que llevar a cabo
inspecciones en una zona de guerra era
de alto riesgo y new crane y sobre de
núcleo en ella es difícil ya he estado
allí dos veces estuve en chernóbil donde
también trabajamos estabilizamos el
lugar estuvo en el sur de ucrania donde
hay otra central nuclear llegar a 10 por
supuesto extremadamente complejo tenemos
que contar con toda la seguridad
seguridad en el sentido de seguridad
física para que no nos disparen aspectos
que hay que cuidar extra ni to be taking
care la central de esa polilla está
ocupada por las fuerzas rusas y
gestionadas por trabajadores ucranianos
desde los primeros días de la guerra que
dura ya seis meses y así objetivo
ataques en las últimas semanas con
bombardeos en sus alrededores
se teme que se produzca una fuga masiva
de radiación la instalación quedó
temporalmente fuera de servicio la
semana pasada el oiea dice que la misión
evaluará ahora los daños físicos de la
instalación determinará la funcionalidad
de los sistemas de seguridad y
protección y evaluará las condiciones
del personal realizando pruebas de
seguridad moscú acusa a ucrania de
disparar imprudentemente contra zab
orilla ucrania dice que rusia la tiene
esencialmente como rehén almacenando
armas allí y lanzando ataques desde sus
alrededores